David should Al Frank and really have resigned
from the Senate given what has happened since
and the gross misconduct that Republicans
have both participated in and excused from
people at all levels of government up to and
including serial assaulter, Donald J. Trump.
Listen, this, this is a complicated thing
to talk about because anytime you say someone
who resigned for some kind of misconduct shouldn't
have done it, it's implied that you are minimizing
or dismissing the importance or the severity
of what they did.
And Al Franken participated in some tasteless
pictures where he, I'm going from memory,
had his hands over the breast area above I
think a flack jacket of a journalist who I
think was sleeping and was wearing a flak
jacket during some kind of trip.
I don't, I don't remember exactly, uh, what
the circumstances were, but I think that the
left needs to be comfortable in these situations
as we've tried to do on the show.
Distinguishing between Al Franken taking part
in a tasteless picture, uh, someone being
accused of making their date uncomfortable
when they were at the person's apartment.
I think that that was the case with Aziz Ansari
is the, I hope I'm remembering correctly,
that is different from a consensual workplace
romance that violates the rules of the workplace.
Right?
So that's an example of the example out of
California 25th that has now led to Christy
Smith and Gengar in the special election,
um, Katie Hill's seat to being accused of
raping someone at the other end of the spectrum
of spectrum, forcible rape.
It's okay to say that these things are different
and you're not excusing any of them.
But this is where you really see a difference
between Republicans and Democrats and I the,
I have no interest in, um, defending or attacking
anyone beyond what they deserve.
On many issues, Democrats and Republicans
are almost or equally corrupt and wrong.
On this particular issue, Republicans had
a guy accused by a dozen women of sexual assault
and they elected him.
President Democrats had Al Franken accused
of participating in an inappropriate picture
and they demanded his resignation.
So my answer is I think the mistake was for
Democrats to demand Frank and resign so quickly.
And I know that in part they did it because
they wanted to appear as though we don't care
what party the person is in.
There was a lot of MuTu stuff happening at
the time, Trump stuff, et cetera, et cetera.
They wanted to appear fair and balanced, for
lack of a better term, but they sort of shot
themselves in the foot because once they called
for Franken to resign, Franken basically has
to resign.
And now in retrospect, I get one or two emails
a week where people say, David, the Democrats
went too far.
Al Franken shouldn't have resigned.
And that is, uh, that he was actually a good
Senator who was doing very, very good things.
I understand it.
Once the calls for his resignation came, I
get why he did it.
I don't think he had a choice at that point,
but I think the mistake was to call for him
to resign so quickly.
I'm not saying maybe eventually that wouldn't
have been what they work out anyway, but I
think it happened reflectively and it happened
too soon.
You know, I'm reminded of Anthony Wiener when
Anthony Wiener was caught sexting some underage
girl.
There were no Democrats defending Anthony
Wiener.
And rightly so, because there was no defense
of that.
And on this issue, Republicans will continue
defending their, a sex assaulters and child
molesters and the entire thing Democrats do,
not sometimes to a fault.
And that's where I end up on it.